blackhead beauty he was a fighter to
tried to beat the fever that took him
then he started asking me about my
mother your mother she was what she
looked like what did you sell him she
died when I was little
sure yello-ha from the very first season
we've known that ginjuries son of King
Robert Baratheon as Ned Stark recognized
it at the moment he laid his eyes on him
just like on the show ginjuries son of
King Robert in the books as well however
the show also provided quite a few clues
leading to a possibility that ginjuries
and just Robert's bastard a traitor
illegitimate son of King Robert and
Queen Cersei by this theory ginjuries a
black-haired beauty son did Cersei
describe to Catelyn the second episode
of the very first season a son she said
had died of a fever when arya asked the
injury about his mother the only thing
he remembered was her yellow hair the
same he already told to her father but
this time Ginji also mentioned that his
mother worked in the tavern then we also
have a scene in which Cersei remembers
how she used to disguise herself as a
tavern wench when she had the secret
meetings with Jaime do you think it's a
coincidence that Gaines remembers his
yellow hair mother who he said looked
like some tavern wench all Cersei on the
other hand said herself that she was
dressing as one to avoid other people
recognizing her well it certainly might
be a coincidence but having in mind that
this is Game of Thrones
the show in which almost every spoken
word has a meaning there might be
something more let's see what other
clues and hints are supporting a theory
in which ginger isn't a bastard but
rather illegitimate son of King Robert
and Queen Cersei just like nedeth
Stannis also recognized that ginjury is
Robert's son as soon as he laid his eyes
on him upon arriving at Dragonstone
Stannis briefly looked over ginjury and
confirmed that he is clearly Robert's
son looking just like he did at that age
this matches with her system and that
her black hair beauty son looks just
like Robert boy look just like him you
might wonder why would Cersei give up on
her firstborn son but the answer is
simple Cersei hasn't lebra birth ever
since their wedding night so she decided
sent the boy away as soon as he was born
so the rightful heir to the throne would
be the child of her and Jaime own that's
assertion that she always hated Robert
Cersei responded with hated him I've
worshipped him every girl in the Seven
Kingdoms dreamed of him but he was mine
by oath and when I finally saw him on
our wedding day in the Sept of Baelor
lean and fierce
and black-bearded it was happiest moment
of my life and that night he crawled on
top of me stinking of wine and did what
he did but little he could do and
whispered in my ear Lyanna your sister
was a corpse I was a living girl and he
loved her more than me
this Circe sentences say itself how much
Cersei hated Robert which eventually
resulted with him being killed by
sources intrigues she did not love
Robert and did not want to raise his son
as an heir of the throne so by this
theory she gave a vague injury in secret
and lied about his death Cersei V
Jamie's help replaced the real baby who
would begin jury with some ordinary
lowborn baby then they poisoned that
lowborn baby causing his death having in
mind that the fever caused child's death
Cersei probably used the same poison
Petyr Baelish endless Iranians to kill
John rain the one that causes fever and
results with certain death recall that
in a dance the Dragons fierce claims to
have switched Rhaegar son with another
baby so infant swaps have happened
before I'm sure most of you are
wondering how would Cersei and Jaime
manage to do all of that without being
noticed by Robert Baratheon
after all Cersei mentions that Robert
was present when their son's body was
taken away so how could her CF center
living child away without her husband
noticing this was very simple to manage
since Robert never attended any of
Circe's child births as Cersei Stated
herself Robert would always go hunting
when she was about to give birth and
when he would return Cersei would
present him with a baby and he would
present her with stag's head his grace
was not with you Robert was hunting
it was his custom whenever my time was
near my royal husband would feed to the
trees with his huntsmen and his hounds
when he returned he would present me
with some pelts or a stag's head and I
would present him with a baby with
Robert of a hunting
Cersei and Jaime could have easily
replaced her son with either poisoned
lowborn baby and present it to Robert
when he returned from the hunt I'm also
wondering if Jon Arryn who visited
ginjury a few times before his death
actually father that Ginjo is the first
and true born son of his dear friend
King Robert Baratheon
what if conversation between Cersei and
Jaime on John's funeral limits expressed
concern for their lives in case Jon told
the truth Robert was the truth about his
first son and the only true born son
what if Jon Arryn told someone but who
would he tell my husband if you told the
King both I had to obscure the city
gates by now whatever Jon Arryn knew or
didn't know it died with him could it be
that Cersei and Jaime were worried dead
Jon might have told someone the truth
about her firstborn child rather than
the truth about her incestuous
relationship with Jaime that's
definitely the case in my opinion pay
attention how Jaime only mentions that
he and Cersei would be executed if
Robert found out the truth wouldn't it
beat them and all three of their
children that would be executed if Lord
the ring found out the truth about their
incestuous relationship
long story short Ned Stark thought he
found out the same truth Lord Arryn dead
but he might have been wrong as I
believe the most important jewel John
knew was the truth about ginjury I know
the truth Jon Arryn died for do you know
to stock it would also raise a question
about Lord Aaron's death which we all
know was orchestrated by Littlefinger
what if Petyr Baelish skill the hand of
the king of course beside the fact that
it gave him an opportunity to marry Liza
who he has already been manipulating but
also to prevent Lord the rein to tell
the truth about ginjuries Robert but why
would a little finger even done that
what good did it bring to him in this
theory well if Lord Arryn managed to
tell King Robert about his only true and
eldest son it wouldn't bring Peter a
chance to pull the Seven Kingdoms into
the state of chaos from which he
benefited it wouldn't bring him a chance
to set up a war between the lions and
wolves it wouldn't bring him a chance to
manipulate Ned Stark which resulted as
he planned with the war
if Lord Arryn told to King Robert about
ginjury Robert would have executed
Cersei and Jaime Lannister and would
have still been alive ginjury would have
been his heir Lord Arryn wouldn't have
been killed Ned Stark wouldn't have
become the hand of the king and the
Seven Kingdoms wouldn't have been in a
state of chaos which wouldn't bring any
success and benefit to Littlefinger
Cersei also recalls that she never
visited her lost child in his script
which seems very odd also Cersei never
mentioned the child's name which could
be a deliberate move on the showrunners
behalf to keep his identity a secret
it's also interesting how ginger grew up
in the slums of flea bottom and yet
managed to land a job with the most
prestigious armor in King's Landing it's
said that when he was old enough an
unknown highborn person paid his
apprentice fee so he could learn to be a
blacksmith ginjury then took up work as
an apprentice blacksmith under mod
forging high-end armed
and weapons for the nobility having in
mind that Robert never even knew of his
existence then which highborn person was
helping injury in my opinion it was his
mother herself Cersei Lannister Circe's
love towards her bloodline combined with
her hatred for Robert and unconditional
love for her children made her give away
Robert child rather than have him killed
so she could have pure Lannister
children that would be heirs to the
throne let me remind you that I already
share this theory over a year ago but
this time I provided you more closer
hints let me know in the comment section
down below if you think injury might be
Circe's black haired son she claims died
shortly after birth well I'm not sure if
this theory is going to come true
ginjuries important role in the upcoming
season is a certain thing with the death
of King Robert the massacre of his
bastard children the deaths of Roberts
brother's friend Lee and Stannis as well
as Stan his daughter
ginjuries left as the last living person
of house Baratheon bloodline
therefore it's safe to say that ginjury
will not only have an important role in
the final season but he will also most
certainly survive Game of Thrones in my
opinion ginjury who is known as a
skilled blacksmith will be very
important in the final season as I'm
expecting from centerfire I'd have to
make Valyrian steel and the most
expecting from ginjury to forge swords
out of it let me also mention that back
in the third season Manuel Sanjay bought
ginjury from the Brotherhood without
banners ganger disappointed that
Brotherhood sold him to Melisandre said
that he thought he was one of them he
said that he thought he was the part of
the Brotherhood without banners on which
most Sancho replied with you are more
than they are ever going to be because
of you the Kings will rise and fall I'm
aware that no Sanjay by this was
pointing on his blood which used for
blood ritual but what if there is more
than that what email Sanjay me is the
true meaning of that what if the Kings
will literally rise and fall because of
him as a result of his own acts good for
an example ginjury caused the fall of
the knight king by forging Valyrian
steel swords so which one will be used
to put an end to the night king in
conclusion judging by all those clothes
hints and proves there's a huge
possibility that ginjury is not just a
bastard but rather a trueborn son of
King Robert Baratheon and Queen Cersei
Lannister be aware that this is a theory
for a TV show only not for the books
Ginji being sir says son certainly is
not possible in the books since the
little dark-haired boy that Cersei gave
birth to in the show does not exist in
books unwilling to give birth to
Robert's child shits and Jaime out to
find a woman to cleanse her having grown
to resent Robert over the years sir
Stephen took an additional care to
ensure he did not impregnate her so
again G being sirs his son sir
is not possible in the books since the
little dark-haired boy that Circe gave
birth to in the show does not exist in
books in the following days you can
expect a video regarding a marriage
between Guinea and Arya we were meant to
rule together if your sister had lived
would have been bound by blood well it's
not too late I have a son you have a
daughter will join our houses